the united states is slowly shutting
down thanks to coronavirus we're seeing
more and more states do what the federal
government has been way too slow to
recommend as we continue to be led by
the blind and the incompetent day after
day after day
the dishonest blind and incompetent
Trump administration I should add and
this is simply going to be the new
reality for a while and I know that it's
horrible it's horrible what's going on
but if we don't start doing these things
it's going to get much worse the stock
market and the economy will likely
suffer far more than what we've already
seen stocks down 12% intraday as we are
filming right now were my prediction is
we could be down 40% from the peaks of a
few weeks ago by the time this is all
said and done although who can ever
predict the bottom but once again
although I hope it doesn't happen we
have to be responsible whatever the
consequences we have to do what your
state says if we want a shot at turning
this around and part of the reason why
we now are increasingly going to more
extreme measures is because the initial
reaction was so incompetent from day one
it'll go away on its own this is no big
deal we have no cases the United States
even with the little amount of testing
that we are doing are rapidly in get
heading in the direction of being one of
the countries with the most cases in the
world now of course we have a really
large population but remember we had
quote leaders telling us we would likely
see very few cases here dr. Anthony
Fauci who's the director of the National
Institute of Allergy and Infectious
Disease he now is saying straight up
cancel or postpone any event with 50 or
people with 50 or more people for eight
weeks eight weeks so as a starting point
that's a long time I get it but
understand that the way these infection
curves go every day that it grows is
another day on the tail end you need for
the decline without a vaccine or
treatments if you have ten days of case
growth before you turn it around you
need 10 days of declines to get back to
where we are today if you delay slowing
down case growth for 15 days you then
need 15 days on the back end before you
get back to where we are today meaning
for every day we don't deal with this we
are actually losing two days minimum
not to mention the exponentially
disastrous effect on the medical system
as I see us become overwhelmed as we
lack ventilators so this will add up
quickly today is day 14 in the United
States of that steady case growth
imagine where we will be in another 14
days if we don't turn it around so in
that context states are starting to shut
down the federal government is is not
doing what they need to do here they
have been far too slow they have been
far too dishonest they're just making
things up whole cloth which I will talk
to you about momentarily so Ohio is
shutting down bars and restaurants
period now remember some places may be
ignoring the decrees at their peril and
it's true that there are places which
will say shut down and people won't do
it and local police are not going to be
able to necessarily enforce every single
bar arrest or not following the rules it
requires people doing it it requires
restaurants doing it Illinois has
ordered bars and restaurants to close
starting tonight until March 30th that's
a couple weeks almost here in
Massachusetts governor Charlie Baker
says all gatherings of more than 25
people are banned restaurants can be
takeout only until April 6th at minimum
and possibly all the way until April
17th some conflicting reports about the
exact dates schools are closed things
are closing down
California Governor Gavin Newsom says
California will be closing bars
nightclubs and wineries and that
everyone aged 65 and over should be self
isolating do not go out in public
Washington State is shutting down
restaurants bars entertainment and
recreational facilities restaurants will
be allowed to do takeout and delivery
there are people who still say you know
there aren't that many cases we have 340
million people and we have 3,500 cases
as of right now
one understand that we don't have 3,500
cases by some estimates we likely have
between 1 and 500,000 cases we are just
not testing we're not testing we don't
know how many cases we have there are
people who will say this this is simply
going too far when you understand the
math of viral contagion you realize you
have to do it because it's too late
because otherwise it's too late it needs
to feel like it's too early because
otherwise you're going to be behind the
curve and look at what happened in Italy
it's a tragedy what's happening in Italy
they did too much too slowly and now
they have more active cases than China
despite having a population that's 96
percent smaller than China's think about
that and that's because of delays every
day matters you've got to turn the
corner on the new case number meaning
you need to change the the inflection of
the curve from more new cases each day
to fewer new cases each day when you
look at new cases in the United States
it's up every day this is the time to
shut it down because otherwise in 10
days the US could look like Italy if
this comes to your state and it likely
will at the rate that we're going be
part of the solution don't be part of
the problem and by the way don't horde
okay the hoarding situations getting
very bad there was no toilet paper
shortage expected rumors swirled that
there would be a shortage think about
why why would all of a sudden there be a
shortage so it doesn't actually make
sense people buying all the toilet paper
they see creates an artificial shortage
and you have tragic stories of elderly
couples driving around all over the
place not feeling well in many cases
looking for a roll of toilet paper
because you have people and I'll play
videos momentarily people fighting it's
like Black Friday looking for the cheap
TV / toilet paper I went to my local a
couple local grocery stores all all
yogurt was gone all eggs were gone all
meat was gone
frozen vegetables frozen from all gone
fresh produce by the way plenty of
people I guess completely ignoring that
at this point
don't horde get you know build up a
strategic supply of a couple of weeks of
food which most of us should have anyway
- a couple weeks is reasonable and non
perishables and understand that you will
make the problem worse it's really
really bad what's going on check out the
excellent YouTube channel we're
partnering up with called
up flip you can get there at david
pakman.com slash up flip the link is
right underneath this video make sure
you subscribe while you are there up
flip is a youtube channel that looks at
entrepreneurship in a very interesting
way their content looks at small
businesses what makes them successful
each video you get to meet a new
entrepreneur get a behind-the-scenes
look at their daily grind learn their
philosophy learn their business as a
business owner myself as someone with an
MBA I love watching the content there's
a ton of really useful insight to come
away with from every episode I love
hearing what the entrepreneurs share you
get practical advice they talk about
outside the box strategies and even if
you don't own a small business yourself
I think you'd be fascinated by the
content on up flip perfect for people
who like shows like Shark Tank and that
sort of thing get to the up flip YouTube
channel by going to david pakman.com
slash up flip the link is underneath the
video they're friends of the david
pakman show definitely make sure to
subscribe to their channel click that
bell icon on their page so you'll be
notified whenever they upload a new
video